so trees that are experiencing stress
from climate change in southern nevada
are going to be those trees that need
more water
so the trees that are not native to the
region or trees that may
normally grow in riparian areas along
streams
those are going to be the trees that are
going to become stressed so climate
change in las vegas and southern nevada
is going to result in increased
frequency of extremely hot days
um and you know more uh severe drought
and uh evapo evaporation
that goes along with that
so selecting trees that are tolerant to
that heat to the to the drought to the
dry soil is really important and native
trees that have evolved in the mojave
desert would be great trees to choose
things like the acacias the the
mesquites the
palo
verdes and trees
uh like that and those are native trees
some non-native trees that that will i
continue to do well over time would be
things like the the tipu tree
um the texas umbrella tree might be a
good choice if if you're willing to
plant non-native trees
the blue palo verde the the desert
museum
palo verde the western honey
mesquite
cultivar maverick which is thornless
these would all be
great choices
so the key to you know identifying
whether your tree is becoming stressed
is to be
in tune to what your tree looks like
normally
and to be aware of any changes that
occur much like
with our own health
and bodies be attuned to the changes and
so the kind of changes that trees
experience when they become stressed is
that they may lose their leaves
prematurely when they normally wouldn't
or when other trees of the same species
are not losing their leaves the leaves
may turn yellow the leaves can be
smaller the canopy can start getting
denser the trees look like it has fewer
leaves of course there can be um
look for signs of acute stress damage to
the trunk um of the tree from equipment
lawn well
maybe not so much lawnmowers in las
vegas anymore but um you know equipment
that can knock the bark off can cause
serious problems for trees but looking
at the um the growth
how much is the tree growing each year
and if that starts declining you look at
the twigs
and notice how
how much the twig is growing on the
branches each year if that starts
reducing that's a sign of stress but the
leaves really provide a lot of of
indication knowing what's normal and
then departures from that